can we celebrate dookie 30 years let's
pretend I'm at the concert okay and one
of the greatest songs from that album is
basket case this is one of the tunes
that you would be doing at the concert
right
absolutely sound B in
case do you have a time to listen to me
whine about nothing and everything
once I am one of those mtic fools neotic
to the B no doubt about
it so does I give myself the
creeps sometimes that mind play tricks
on
me it all keep setting
up cck it up and my
[Music]
choise I went to a shrink to aning
dreams she said it's like a su bringing
me
down I went to a we s my
life so qu
my bringing her
down sometimes I give myself a
creep my tricks on
me all keeping
up think going back it up and my just
[Music]
beeny
rasping to
control so better
[Music]
hold
sometimes I give myself the
[Music]
CR it does my mind Place F on
me we all keep setting up while
it might just
Paro
[Music]
St
oh
wow that song holds up man watching
you guys play that is the most fun thing
I could ever
watch